we'll start the show in just a second
but first i want to tell you about
today's
sponsors nebia is a revolutionary shower
head that saves you money by using 45
percent less water but with a stream of
water that's way more powerful
than what you get with other shower
heads to get fifteen percent off
go to nebia.com pacman and use the code
pacman
blinkist is the app that helps you
become a more well-rounded person by
letting you read or listen to an
entire non-fiction book in just 15
minutes you can try it for free
and get 25 off a subscription by going
to blinkist.com
david pakman if you're trying to quit
smoking or vaping check out lucy which
is a nicotine gum developed by caltech
scientists they'll ship it right to your
door and you can save
twenty percent when you go to lucy.co
and use coupon code pacman we are
um unfortunately potentially
approaching a very dangerous
period um not ideologically
but in a very sort of literal and
and pragmatic sense a dangerous period
what could be
dangerous for many americans because
president donald trump
in his latest series of rage tweets
amplified a message
reportedly from one of his fans that
things are soon to escalate
and it could be a dangerous moment in
america which of course is likely to
have the effect of planting that idea
in his followers and actually making it
so a self-fulfilling prophecy of sorts
so let me back up and kind of give you
the genesis of all of this yesterday
morning
after a couple of days of relative calm
on twitter and i used that
phrase very very loosely um donald trump
amplified some dangerous messages and
also
sent some messages of his own attacking
joe biden attacking republican governor
brian kemp
and this now is of getting to be
extremely concerning over what is going
to be a
five or six week period of this nonsense
i predict it started with a sort of
strange
all-capital letters tweet where donald
trump said merely wisdom and courage
very strange thing to say and then he he
quoted an
unnamed fan supposedly from one of his
rallies as reported
supposedly by propaganda network oan and
this is where donald trump amplifies the
idea
of a dangerous moment with huge
escalations saying quote
and this is quote quote this is me
quoting trump quoting oan
quoting a trump supporter people are
upset they have a right to be
georgia not only supported trump in 2016
but now
that's untrue of course this is the only
state in the deep south that went for
biden
have they lost their minds and yeah i
mean biden one that's it
this is going to escalate dramatically
this is a very dangerous moment
in our history the fact that our country
is being stolen a coup is taking place
in front of our eyes and the public
can't take this anymore
now that's all untrue and trump quotes
a trump fan at a georgia rally per
oan and then says bad after that
donald trump went after republican
georgia governor brian kemp
why because kemp won't illegally steal
the election for trump
kemp is no good guy i really want people
to understand this
when when i've been saying this week
kemp doesn't seem willing to try to
steal georgia for trump
i believe kemp kemp is horrible kemp
participated in voter suppression
in the very election in which he was a
candidate for governor
against stacey abrams kemp has overseen
the continued purging of voter rolls and
everything else that we've been talking
about
and i wouldn't even put it past kemp to
try to steal georgia
if doing so would give trump the
presidency what what
may be going on here is kemp realizes
even
if i try to fraudulently steal georgia
for trump
trump still doesn't win it just reduces
the number of electoral votes
by which joe biden wins and so listen
kemp's no good guy but trump's furious
with him because kemp won't try to steal
it for him
trump tweeting how does governor brian
kemp allow certification of votes
without verifying signatures and despite
the recently released tape of ballots
being stuffed remember that those tapes
have been
completely debunked his poll numbers has
have dropped like a rock
he is finished as governor i have no i
mean listen
uh as we spoke about yesterday with
benjamin dixon
there's a lot of republican infighting
in georgia this may
all damage in the end calculation
the final math this may hurt brian kemp
or it may not with georgia republicans
we don't know
but it's certainly not clear at this
time and of course most of these tweets
flagged by twitter as being misleading
or disputed
and then donald trump merely calling on
the supreme court to steal the election
for him saying quote
the supreme court has a chance to save
our country
capital c country from the greatest
capital e
election abuse in the history
of the united states 78 of the people
feel know the election was rigged
so when trump chooses to quote
and amplify some alleged follower who's
saying
this is about to escalate and this will
become a dangerous moment for the united
states
it's very very dangerous for trump to do
now trump can hide behind
i didn't say it i was quoting a fan
but it's fanning the flames when the
president does this
it's dog whistling when the president
does this and this could get very
ugly very quickly and i have no idea
what trump supporters are willing to do
what are they capable of
as they are inevitably seeing i mean
it's happening daily every lawsuit
getting tossed
each day trump continues to claim he won
and each day leads us to nothing other
than being one day closer to joe biden
being sworn in as president
on january 20th so it is scary
and um i get emails you know two three
four emails a day not dozens like when i
you know say the wrong thing but two
three four emails a day from people who
are saying listen i live in
this red state i'm worried about this or
that
because these people are furious these
people
literally believe the things that donald
trump is saying they're not
you know they don't interpret i was
robbed as i should have won but i didn't
they interpret i was robbed as specific
democrats
manipulated votes and stole and
cheated and hacked and all this
different stuff
and that the will of the people was that
donald trump would win they literally
believe that that's what trump is saying
and who knows what they are potentially
willing to do
um we all we can do is follow it and see
and hope for the best
this is sort of a funny detail about the
presidential transition typically during
the inauguration
there's this few hour period during
which furniture is swapped out at the
white house for the incoming president
artwork has changed there's a little bit
of redecorating that's done and
it's you know all happening very very
quickly because of the coronavirus
pandemic
this time around there's an extra detail
which is that joe biden has already made
plans
to spray down the entire white house
with disinfectant in that interim period
after trump leaves and before joe biden
arrives as you probably know the white
house has been
suffering a plague of coveted infections
that includes trump himself and many
other people i won't list them
so they're going to go in and hit the
doorknobs and
everything and for me this is more about
the optics and the poetic meaning of
disinfecting the white house from trump
because
listen we learned remember early on in
the pandemic where people were
uh bleaching uh of groceries including
just like boxed groceries where you
could just open the box and anyway
and then we found out that the surface
transmission was really quite low
that was probably a bit overblown um so
for me
this is this is not really about
spraying down
the white house with disinfectant
misting disinfectant
to literally prevent someone who works
for biden from catching the virus from a
surface
v via someone who worked for trump for
me it's more about the poetic meaning
of going through the white house misting
disinfectant everywhere
it's more about the metaphor of
getting rid of trump and his failed
response to the pandemic
you still love to see it the visual is
going to think about is hilarious
but it's more for me about cleaning the
white house not literally of trump's
germs
but of the incompetent leadership of the
virus i'm calling this
fumigate i'm not even a dad and i was
able to tell that joke
i was actually thinking though um so
first my thought was maybe biden should
sleep somewhere else a few days and give
it
48 72 hours before walking into the
white house
but the truth is trump may well be gone
by then this is the other story and
we've been covering this for the last
seven to ten days
it's still unclear whether donald trump
is going to stick around and actually go
to the inauguration
one other possibility is he will fly out
right before the inauguration
directly to a rally at which he will
continue to claim he won
or maybe even announce his 2024
candidacy that would be
completely corrosive to democracy he
might also head to florida in just about
10 or 15 days
for christmas and new year and just not
come back to washington dc that's
another speculation we really don't know
and we don't care as long as he leaves
now if i were biden to be safe
i would spray i would treat for bed bugs
i would
check for electronic bugs as well
check for false paneled walls check
melania's rose garden
for listening devices put the solar
panels back
on i would do the whole thing if i were
joe biden
and think about how quickly things have
changed
where at the beginning of this pandemic
before any of them even remotely
accepted this might be a big thing
republicans were joking about wearing
gas masks remember matt gates wearing a
big gas mask on the floor of congress he
ended up getting the virus
they were making fun of china having
trucks spraying disinfectant
and just months later the incoming
president
is going to have disinfectant sprayed in
much the same manner
throughout the white house to clean it
from the outgoing president things
change very quickly
my only concern is let's start figuring
this out let's get competent leadership
we know that joe biden
is going to mandate masks at federal
buildings we know joe biden is going to
ask americans to wear masks for a
hundred days
we are hoping that we will start getting
five six seven
percent of the us population vaccinated
each month
hopefully starting this month maybe only
a few percent this month
and five six seven eight percent in
january
another five to eight percent in
february and we're going to we're going
to start
um hopefully the economic recovery will
come with it we're going to talk about
second coronavirus stimulus
we're going to be here and there's going
to be so much to do but this transition
is metaphorical in as much of a sense as
it is literal
let me know what you think i'm on
twitter at d pacman and we've got
a great show for you today the david
pakman show
at davidpakman.com
[Music]
one of our sponsors today is nebia the
creator of the world's most
innovative shower head it uses only
about
half the water that other shower heads
do saving you money helping the
environment
but it's actually a lot more powerful
than other shower heads on the market it
has twice the coverage of other shower
heads
the water sprays with a ton of pressure
i've been using it in my bathroom at
home
i love it only took a few minutes to set
up really easy and it's been a totally
different
experience than any other shower head
i've used i can get in and out of the
shower way quicker now
because of how powerful it is it only
takes a few seconds to get
completely rinsed off so i was actually
amazed that it's only using about half
as much
water nebia also offers a number of
shower accessories like shelves and
curtains which match
perfectly with the design of the shower
head the shower head starts at just
199 but the first hundred people to go
to nebia.com
pacman and use the code pacman will get
15 off site wide
[Music]
the david pakman show at davidpakman.com
remember that the number one way to
support the david pakman show
is to get yourself a membership at
joinedpakman.com you may not know this
because i mentioned it so infrequently
but we do have a membership program
joinedpakman.com is the place to sign
up let's hear from some folks in the
audience we're getting close to the end
of the year we will soon have a new
president what is on folks minds
you can talk to me through our discord
server davidpakman.com
slash discord let's go first
to kelsey from colorado
kelsey from colorado you're on the air
what's going on
hey david can you hear me yes i can
awesome
uh well hey i'm a big fan of the show
thank you been watching
ever since i think august so it's been
keeping me mentally sane
i love it um i guess my question is
what do you think is the end game for um
the republican party as a whole i know
they're kind it seems like
they're fragmented and i saw um
the footage of blue doll lou dobbs and
stephen miller kind of
figuring out what what's happening and
i'm just kind of
to see what is the long game
for them to stay in existence because i
i just don't see it happening with
more people seeming to get involved in
younger generations coming
up um what do you think is their endgame
so you mean you don't mean just between
their their antics between now and
inauguration day for biden you mean like
really long term for the survival of the
party
because honestly like they'll keep going
but i think it seems
that more people are going to get tired
of it yeah and
um i i feel like it's not sustainable so
i don't know if they're playing to just
reform or what the deal is but what do
you think is their in-game
you know people have been asking this
for so long and for a long time
now we've been hearing the republican
party will eventually
go out of existence because subsequently
younger generations are more and more on
the left
that reversed a little bit because
actually young voters supported trump at
a slightly
higher level than we would have expected
relative to past republicans in 2020 or
demographic changes including more
latino voters going to some key red
states are going to make those states
purple and eventually blue and the
republican party won't be sustainable
so far that's not happened now part of
the reason kelsey it hasn't happened is
voter suppression gerrymandering right
figuring out ways
other than winning the hearts and minds
of voters to keep winning by preventing
people from voting or whatever the case
may be
i think that the important takeaway is
um predictions of the republican party's
demise
on demographic grounds have fallen
short for decades at this point so we
should not assume
that they will simply uh go out of
existence because of the platform i
i believe that they will it's not even
going to be reform but they will just
tweak and adjust to continue
raising a lot of money from donors on
key wedge issues
keep suppressing the vote and and they
are not going to go away what they will
look like in 10 or 20 years i don't
pretend to know
gotcha yeah that makes sense i feel like
they're i i
that's what my fear is is that the
reforming is just going to get more and
more
ensconced and um you're just going to
have to fight harder to
resist that i i agree and in particular
now
with you know completely
propaganda-based news outlets everything
from
you know breitbart gateway pundit
newsmax oan which people
think are actual news it's going to be a
big fight it's going to be a big fight
we can't underestimate the importance of
that so
it's a big battle we have ahead of us
right right
well great thanks for uh taking my call
and talking to me
all right kelsey from colorado very much
appreciate that uh
that call uh we are taking calls at
davidpakman.com
discord let's go next
to jagger from chicago
jagger from chicago you're on the air
hello hello
how are you i'm pretty good how are you
good
uh with trump going to florida and such
supposedly when he leaves the white
house
yeah does you know sort of thing
uh does this sort of remind you of like
how the civil war started
in terms of history of uh him going to
florida and sort of succeeding from
there in the sense of like
trump goes trump goes to the south and
maybe
generates a rebellion from like a
parallel position
of leadership down at mar-a-lago or
something
yeah similar to how the civil war
started i don't think so
i really don't think so i mean you know
it's always like
if if you uh i'm i'm here's the thing
that's difficult about this
i don't know if you're familiar uh
jagger with the book
uh black swans by naseem nicholas talib
have you heard of that book
i have not this nasim talib
works with the idea of rare events
and the fundamental nature of how it's
difficult to
because these black swan events are so
rare
there's no way to properly account for
them in our thinking so like a former
president going to florida
and starting uh the equivalent of a
modern confederacy generating a civil
war
because it would be such a black swan
event it's hard
to to really take it too seriously so
obviously in retrospect we may say oh my
god obviously that's what trump did it
was one of these black swan events
but it does not strike me as as
particularly likely
oh okay and do you think there's gonna
be genuine healing then in that case
genuine healing administration uh
no probably not i mean you understand
that at this point you have
such a highly weaponized piece of the
electorate
um that i mean we've had partisanship
for a long time that's not new
but you you've seen trumpism and
the uh sort of uh legitimization of some
of these propaganda right-wing media
outlets
lead to a really difficult situation to
actually heal because listen i mean we
may have an inauguration day jagger
where the news networks are broadcasting
the swearing-in of the new president
and oan and newsmax are broadcasting a
trump rally in florida and don't even
cover the fact that there's a new
president like we
we may actually see that and that's not
an environment where there's going to be
any real healing to speak of
well thank you for taking my call it's
unfortunate this is the way it is but
yeah
my pleasure thank you jagger from
chicago
uh very much appreciate hearing from you
let's go next to roland from vienna now
is that vienna austria or i know that
there's cities and towns called vienna
in the united states as well
that's vienna austria david beautiful
from europe beautiful you know
i if we did not have the virus i would
have been in vienna
in august and i could be talking with
you right now about my favorite
restaurants in vienna but unfortunately
i didn't go because of the virus
well listen mate i have a second
apartment that i was using to
uh for covet it was quite convenient
yeah so give me a ring flop on over
all right i will take it what do you
have a quick king size bed or am i to
have to sleep in like a bunk
separate apartment dude no no i know but
does the apartment have
a a big bed or a small bed
um regular regular people regular
queen size is american so it's just a
double i love it
i love it so listen i'm from austria
right and i'm watching this well
i was watching it it's safe harbor day
now but 2016 we elected our president
yeah and that got we did a do-over
because uh our right-wingers did exactly
what yours are doing
they went to the courts and on uh
on uh you know on uh what do you call it
like official errors
they they called the election back and
we had to do a do-over
i'm not familiar with that wrote that's
that's uh that's scary
i still don't think it was the
presidential election yeah and it was
funny because we ended up saying
uh it was the most successful election
of the right-wing party
and we ended up saying well they they uh
successfully challenged it
yeah they successfully challenged their
most successful election and then lost
so we pulled together you know
so is your is your message a message of
warning that
it could happen here as well a lot of
people are saying
it's impossible i think it is now after
safe harbor day
yeah but it has happened in western
civilized countries
and i think this will be important this
will be the end this will be the mo
going forward for a lot of right-wing uh
crazy parties they will just try to
steal elections they've lost
yes yes yes yes i don't disagree i have
a quick question yes
do you think biden is going to do the
full term everyone's talking about trump
2024 he's going to be a
very old man i don't even see biden
doing the full term
in fact i would be interested what do
you think the chances are that biden
hands over
after the 2022 midterm elections to
kamala
to allow her to be in the driving seat
for her first election
i mean again that would be such a rare
event in presidential history that me
saying
i think it's this percent or that
percent would would essentially be
meaningless
um i i i am aware of the actuarial
tables and life expectancy
and i have a sort of realistic
understanding of the fact that
joe biden is 78 and donald trump uh
would would be that age or even older if
he were to run in 24 but i i wouldn't be
able to make any specific prediction but
i do expect joe biden to serve a full
term
great listen dave uh long time listener
you really uh
i like your style neutral but still left
leaning
and you know i think everyone knows
because if you look at sam cedar's
uh youtube account numbers he's not even
at the 1 million mark yet
that's a low blow sorry that's a low
blow that's a low blow that's aggressive
roland
thank you well i'll i'll leave you i'll
leave you with this low blow you know
i also don't think that you need your
own your own only fans channel
okay i think you can show your zook off
on your
tremendous boner show that'll be
sufficient for us all right roland from
vienna and
uh roland are you pro or anti-salzburg
austria is it good there is it nice
so my parents are there it's uh you know
very hoity-toity
oh um it's nice it's nice the rural
areas are nice yeah
again it's very it's very condensed us
viennese we say
salzburg and vienna has the same amount
of tourists but salzburg is ten
ten times as small so right right and
can you can you get a can you get a good
cappuccino in salzburg
oh oh listen david i'm sorry to quote
you
[ __ ] your cappuccino because it's
melange in austria oh is that what it's
called there
melange a viennese melange yeah vienna
is the home of coffee house culture
well listen i'm gonna have to go there
when you're here please
thank you all right roland from vienna
and uh producer pat we will have to we
will have to bleep the f-bomb that was
very very strongly dropped there
uh but he felt very strongly about it
and and so i sort of um
i sort of understand i guess i would say
let's go
next to uh let's go to tai
from connecticut tai from connecticut
you're on the air
hey how's it going good yeah vienna
sounds pretty nice right now
yeah for uh with that other place
i my question is a two-parter okay and
it's a little more abstract that
then i think the other question's been a
little more direct a little more kind of
in the weeds do you think that donald
trump
is an effective political
communicator well
see here's what's very interesting
trump's
statements trump's delivery is one of
the most incoherent i've ever heard from
a president
in the sense that he will you know
make up words say things that don't make
sense say one thing and then say the
opposite
never answer a question lie like it
analyzing it objectively you can barely
put together a sentence
if you're if you're like logical and
rational but at the same time
which is what i'm going to do at the
same time his way his method of
communication
has been hugely effective to the people
that are even likely to consider voting
for him
right so right his method won't work for
somebody
who sees trump and says this is a
grotesque
ignorant buffoon but for folks who
are open to the idea of being told the
reason you don't make more money is
because of china and i will fix it or
mexico and i will fix it it it actually
is effective so so the answer it's not a
there's not a clear-cut answer it
depends on who you're trying to appeal
to
right so the second part is
and you can you can rearrange the
question
how you want but i kind of want to try
to
do a broader subject which is do you
think sort of the democratic
establishment
uh the you know i don't know the dnc
nancy pelosi uh chuck schumer
barack obama joe biden hillary clinton
do you think that they
are effective political communicators
and i'm gonna actually add this too
yeah uh and you can you can answer it
however you want but
i maybe you can even touch back on the
trump thing i think when i think of the
question like effective political
communicator i think of like
getting what they want done whether
whatever what they want is if i or you
might disagree with it
do you think that they are effective
political communicators in that way and
i'm just gonna the reason why i'm asking
the question is i don't think they are
and i suspect that you might and i
i want to hear kind of like your
explanation why you do because honestly
of the people
of the people you listed the only one
that i think is
really an effective political
communicator is barack obama yeah
right i mean it's like nancy pelosi and
chuck schumer you know they're they're
in the positions they're in not because
of
being gifted speakers they're in the
positions they're in because of being
gifted schmoozers and fundraisers
and insiders um as far as hillary
clinton and joe biden
you know joe biden is not what he was at
one point i think
in the late uh in the early 2000s
and while he was vice president i think
joe biden was quite an effective
political communicator although he
wasn't always in positions of
of that speech making as big of a
difference but of the people you listed
barack obama is the one that really you
know bill clinton in his heyday was a
very effective political communicator
and as you're saying this is aside from
policy
but no the people you listed mostly are
not great communicators
what then you have to consider as a
whole sort of the democratic
establishment and look
is the republican establishment good
political communicators i'm not
sure maybe to their demographic yes
exactly
i guess just to sort of uh round up the
question
the democratic establishment as a whole
if they want to
you know and this is this is kind of
where i get frustrated presumably their
agenda
is not the republicans agenda right so
i mean you know if if you have an agenda
that's not the republicans agenda
are you effective at getting people to
be motivated
to politically whether it be vote for
you or whatever go
you know vote in the senate whatever you
know are
are you you know and this is where i
kind of from the left get
really concerned and i think that your
comments have been actually rather
refreshing
but yeah as the establishment because i
think this is where they need to
you know i think i think everyone thinks
this and is looking at this honestly
like you know
you know it's like a branding problem i
guess if you're yeah and listen that's
we've been you know check out my
interview from who knows how long ago
uh with george lakoff about this issue
like i've not i've not hesitated to uh
to to point this out it's absolutely a
problem listen i've gotta run because
i've got a bunch of people to get to i
appreciate the call
we're taking just a very very quick
break if you're holding on to talk to me
don't hang up because i'll be going
right back to the phones momentarily
the david pakman show at davidpakman.com
[Music]
what if you could read 10 books in just
one sitting that's exactly
what one of my favorite apps lets you do
it's called blinkist and what they do is
take
thousands of popular nonfiction books
they condense them down
into text or audio that you can consume
in 15 minutes
blinkist makes sure that you're getting
all of the
important core insights from each book
so it's perfect for exploring a book you
otherwise wouldn't have time for
if there's a full book you're thinking
about buying you can use blinkist to get
a sample
first just think how much you can enrich
yourself
by being able to soak up an entire
nonfiction book
in just 15 minutes i recently read a
brief history of time of course by the
great stephen hawking this is a book
that i have been aware of for so long
and
other things got in the way and it was
fantastic to check it out on blinkist
blinkist has books on politics
philosophy science they have 27
different non-fiction categories and a
subscription is only about eight bucks a
month
and you get the entire library but
you can try it totally free and get
twenty five percent off a subscription
when you go to blinkist.com
slash david pakman i've put the link
right underneath this video
[Music]
welcome back to the david pakman show
let's get back to the phones we now we
call them phones they're really the
internet tubes we're taking calls via
discord at davidpakman.com
discord let's go to jane from singapore
jane from singapore you're on the air
hi hi how are you i am i'm very well
thank you
wow i'm surprised you called on me oh no
jane from singapore is exactly what we
would gravitate towards
i i think that your show has been very
enlightening for me
thank you and i basically
signed up to be a member because i
watched your video with um
this other guy um i can't remember his
name though
um and basically i thought he was so he
he was a right wing
um believer i believe and you were just
so polite
and so conversational and so accepting
of listening to his views and i just
respected that so much
wow i can tell you who that was was it
uh was it maybe tim poole was he wearing
a hat during the interview
no it was it was black guy who
who just said peterson jesse lee
peterson
yes that's right that's the one got it
so i mean i i think that you know
the way the u.s system has been running
is
it's a great disappointment because we
all looked at the us as
honestly a shining beacon of democracy
and i'm just wondering honestly you know
how
how the system would run with i mean
even republicans showing
a great drift um you know on one hand
you have
a bunch of guys who are denying that
the elections outcomes are uh
illegitimate
and on the other hand people are saying
you know uphold election results the
republicans are saying there's no fraud
how how does that even work in a party
how do you go forward from here yeah i
mean listen it's it's really a question
for them to answer
because as someone who's on the left i
see it and i say this is corrosive and
destructive to democracy
this is going to um uh
lead to if this is believed by a
significant portion of the population
it's going to lead to all sorts of
follow-on problems
to me it seems untenable and
unsustainable now it's interesting that
you're saying from the perspective of
looking at what's going on from
singapore
it's not so much that you find it funny
you find it disturbing it sounds like
i do yeah i find it i find it how
how trump has weaponized the two words
fake news
i'm very disturbing people you know how
do people raise
kids on such values i mean you know
there's others talk about
recovery um healing the country
but do the people democrats and
republicans the people on you know
on the street do they actually take the
first steps towards recovery towards
conversation towards dialogue
no of course in fact i would expect
so if donald trump announces that his
2024 candidacy
soon i think that we will have four
years of of insanity once again
um and i think that either way the
presence of these propaganda media
outlets like newsmax and oan that are
going to
i mean they are go i can't even guess
what sorts of conspiracies they will
come up with about joe biden over the
next four years
it's going to be the opposite of healing
that we see here
can i ask a question just just get your
viewpoint yeah
um do you think that donald trump will
try to cut a deal with
the doj perhaps to say
you know i will i will completely accept
the election results
if you guys just not charge me
or pursue any sort of criminal
investigations no chance because so so
because here's the thing here's the
thing jane if he does it now
it's his own doj so so what that that
doesn't make sense
and then that's not something that the
biden do i mean biden will be president
in a month you know so biden doesn't
need to cut any deals with anybody
and i i don't see i think the only way
trump can get himself out of trouble
preemptively
would be resign and mike pence pardons
him i don't think he will do it but
there are rumors he's thinking about it
i see i see because that's what we're
talking about in singapore we're sort of
betting that he would
he would step down in peace and say i
will give you country peace
only if you know right guys do not
prosecute me
yeah i don't think that will happen i
don't think that will happen no
all right anyway good luck and all the
best and i hope that um there will be a
very smooth
and gorgeous inauguration yes ceremony
jane from singapore very much appreciate
the call
uh great to hear from folks not just all
over the country but all over the world
let's go next to um let's go to
kyle from daytona beach florida
kyle from daytona beach florida you're
on the air
mr pacman can you hear me yes i can
excellent it's a pleasure to speak with
you the pleasure is all my content is
thank you thank you your content is very
intellectually stimulating it's a nice
reprieve
from everything that i have to hear
every day living in a red state
thank you now i i know that some people
are going to get mad at me because they
say i
listen i haven't brought up anybody's
connection at all
but we are getting sort of like an
electricity type static as well as a
banging noise so i'm wondering what
you're doing
i'm sitting on my bed i can turn off the
fan and shut my bedroom's door
quickly you're not crinkling pieces of
paper over the phone by chance
wow oh my god we're gonna have to turn
that down that isn't
okay yeah we're gonna have to disconnect
that's just that was i don't even know
that that's legal in some states
um we're gonna i really wanna hear from
you but we're gonna have to get i can't
subject the audience to that and the
audiologists in the audience are filing
lawsuits so
not gonna be able to do that at this
point in time
uh okay let's go next
to um wow
i'm shell shocked by that let's go to
will from dc
will from dc you're on the air hi can
you hear me
yes i can yes hi i wanted to um
speak i guess about the uh
yeah and sorry about you cut out right
when you said the key thing
you want to speak about what yeah the
right-wing media okay
um i i think we all have relatives who
you know they're they're afraid of
things that we
sort of have difficulty comprehending
i guess i guess my question is you know
with covid and a lot of what's going on
with
dangers of the virus and climate change
how much do you think that
uh the government is going to get better
at i guess
aligning what people are actually in
danger from
and what their fears are i guess as
when it comes to right wing propaganda i
know that you know
rush limbaugh's four horsemen of the
apocalypse with uh
science being one of them is something
that's out to get
with all the misinformation with covid
and everything that's going on do you
think that the government
sort of in terms of institutions and
public awareness is going to be
a little more aggressive about trying to
insert themselves into that into that
into that loop and try to subvert a lot
of this misinformation that's going on
about
you know i mean i there are people who
are more afraid that you know antifa is
going to hurt them then they're going to
die of heart disease in their 60s and
obviously that's ridiculous
so in other words it's like we know that
people dramatically overstate
how likely they are to be victims of a
terrorist attack
but they dramatically understate how
likely they are for example to get into
a car accident which is
overwhelmingly more common exactly and i
think that's one of the government's
main
functions is to is to try to align our
fears
and from to what we're actually in
danger of being harmed by
right i mean listen if the if as a
country and when i say that i don't mean
just some people if if 330 million
people
all understood the virus for example
we would have way fewer deaths because
people would be cooperating
if more people understood the risk from
climate change
we would not have the politicization
that we do
as to what to do about climate change i
completely agree with you i don't know
how you change that narrative
because when you have such a weaponized
disinformation propaganda network of uh
of channels
um combined with educational issues
combined with partisanship used to raise
money i don't know how you start doing
it but i'm completely on board with you
as far as identifying the problem that
people misjudge the risks they over
and understate the risks in different
areas in ways that are
counterproductive absolutely i i guess
do you think the bind administration is
going to
maybe have government institutions that
are more proactive about public
awareness about this kind of stuff i
hope so i mean listen their first big
test will be the virus
fauci's going to be working uh with
biden
and he's bringing in a coronavirus sort
of chief or czar jeff
i think his name is i forget his name
exactly and he's gonna ask for a hundred
days of mask wearing and he's gonna
oversee the vaccine distribution let
that
that'll be the first test let's check in
in you know april 15th and see how it's
going
absolutely well thank you i appreciate
your comment my pleasure uh great to
hear from you
a lot of very interesting calls today at
davidpakman.com
slash discord let's oh this is
interesting
let's go to ferris from saudi arabia
you're calling from saudi arabia right
now
yes i am nice to meet you dave likewise
and are you
are you saudi or are you someone working
or living there
no i'm originally from saudi uh i'm
living here
in called the city um
yes i am is the david pakman show big in
saudi arabia
to be honest i'm not hundred percent
sure yeah because i've been watching
some news about what happened this
uh covert night king oh the case is like
over 15 million my god i'm very
shocked yes yes indeed
well what can i do for you today yeah
um i have a question about donald trump
i don't when i see the on the news um
something about the operation warp suite
yes it all all this election all this in
a
it's all it's a complete mess and now
he's making a softball
full of it i don't know how the
um sorry my cat wasn't me yeah i can
hear your your cat seems very very
aggressive always like this
um just
one second please sure sure listen i may
even have more questions
for you but yeah yeah go on
so uh how do you feel about um opening
up women driving
is that something you're you like
hmm not really but i was kind of
surprised that women finally can drive
uh uh in aura but
that's the good news but so hold on a
second you said you don't like it but it
is good news
no no no no i'm i didn't say i don't
like it any
uh i'm not i don't know the the question
to be honest
no no i'm just asking are you in favor
of women
getting the the ability to uh the legal
ability to drive in saudi arabia
hmm yeah i
i think they have a ability to drive
no i understand of course they have the
physical ability just like anybody else
but are you
politically speaking do you do you like
that are you in favor of it
in favor uh
do you support women driving in saudi
arabia
yeah i support it you do sorry about
that that's great
because my sister i have a sister to be
honest because she needs to drive
as well right as a practical matter you
support it
yes yeah all right first listen um
this is all very very interesting i'm
gonna let you go because we do have a
lot of people waiting but a very
interesting phone call um and
we had a cat and we had a number number
of different things going on there
uh let's go next to where do we want to
go next because there's just such a
plethora of people wanting to get on
why don't we go to um let's go to zayler
from rhode island zayler from rhode
island you're on the air
hello david how are you today i'm doing
well thank you i must say i love discord
for some reason on the phone line i
would
uh you would say something and i would
hear it 10 seconds later so this is much
nicer
that's beautiful all right so if we win
both the senate seats in georgia which i
hope we do with awesome
uh warnock yes how likely is it
that there might be a democrat defector
in the senate that might cause a problem
so i know that for instance
joe manchin he's still in the senate in
west virginia
is it that despite us getting 50 seats
that that's going to be
uh an issue for us i
i agree i mean listen when you think
about something like
you know uh the public option that joe
biden wants
um it's not even clear every democrat
supports that i don't know if joe
manchin
supports that so the 50 50 with kamala
as the tiebreaker
is the starting point but you are going
to potentially have a lot of trouble
actually whipping all the votes that
that you would need to even get to the
50
so i completely agree with you now on
the other side of that there may be some
reason
slightly marginally more reasonable
republicans that would be willing to
come over as well
but i think you're completely right that
just getting to 50 50 with kamala as the
theoretical tie-breaking vote it doesn't
really get big legislation
legislation done it's still going to be
a big fight
yeah and obviously the moderate dems are
slaves to their districts whoever
elected them
are there even any republicans who could
be persuaded over for legislation like
that like that could defect from their
side
it depends on the issue completely
you're not going to get susan collins to
come over and say
medicare for all right but there there
are certainly
ways in which you know there are
probably funding related things
or or you know priorities or whatever
where joe manchin because of his west
virginia electorate might not be with
the democrats
but susan collins because of the main
electorate
might be with the democrats so there are
definitely examples but you're not going
to pass like
tax reform biden's tax reform proposal
you're not going to get that because of
republicans with joe manchin
not participating that's not going to
happen you're going to need every
democrat for that
and how much of a problem of thorn in
the side do you think the filibuster
might be
if we do get um very close margins on
legislation i think it will be a problem
i i think that
if if democrats do get 50 50
and biden is in a position to pass some
major legislation
i do think the issue of the filibuster
will come up but on what issue i don't
yet know
and what do you think so far with the
supreme court that
we have now yeah and even previous to
the death of rgb or rbg rather
rbg right um the
legislation i mean the cases rather that
pass through the supreme court
i remember that there was the victory
with the
anti-discrimination for trans people if
i remember correctly but that happened
not too long ago
do you see any uh cases or any
important decisions being made by the
supreme court that could be negative
given
uh the now uh very cemented conservative
majority
on the court absolutely i wouldn't be
able to say what we first have to see
what comes before the court but i i'm
very worried about uh
about the supreme court for sure listen
i've got to run sailor but i appreciate
the call i love that so many people
called in i'm not able to take more
calls
today but we will take more calls soon
and we will take a quick break and be
back with much more
the david pakman show at davidpakman.com
[Music]
one of our sponsors today is lucy and
they are giving my audience
20 off lucy is a company founded by
caltech scientists with only one mission
which is to help people quit smoking
and vaping by offering a clean
affordable
nicotine alternative now many of you
know you've heard the stories
i've known several people in my life who
have struggled with quitting smoking
i've seen how difficult it can be and
nicotine alternatives can be hugely
helpful
lucy offers a nicotine gum in three
flavors wintergreen cinnamon and
pomegranate they also have lozenges
which come in cherry ice
flavor lucy is affordable it'll ship
right to your door you don't have to go
out to the store
shipping is always free you can buy
single boxes or save with a subscription
it's the year 2020. it's time to throw
the cigarettes away
and get rid of the vape and lucy can
make it easier you'll find
a ton of excellent reviews online from
countless people
who have used lucy to quit smoking and
vaping
go check them out at lucy.co i've put
the link right underneath this video and
you'll get 20
off when you use the coupon code pacman
and just a quick disclaimer i'm required
to give
these products contain nicotine nicotine
is an addictive chemical
[Music]
the david pakman show at davidpakman.com
all right let's get directly into
audience questions for the week
first one is one i've gotten from a lot
of people what happens to donald trump's
adult children once he's out of office
the the answer will uh depend on
things we don't yet know um we've talked
about the possibility
that some of trump's children might run
for office
we've talked about the possibility that
trump's children
uh or or children in law would for
example run for senate as lara trump is
reportedly thinking about doing
in north carolina they may go back to
private industry
they may be really tied up with
investigations for some time
and that is why donald trump has
reportedly been considering preemptive
pardons for them
what we do know is that they're sort of
re-entry into private life
is not going to put them back where they
were before this entire presidential
fiasco
uh for example in new york city uh
wanted signs
have been showing up uh for ivanka and
jared kushner
except they say not wanted they are not
welcome back
in new york city and there have been
some interesting articles written about
how
they are not likely to be sort of like
re-accepted into the
left-leaning new york city social scene
i don't feel bad for them at all but it
is interesting and recent news is that
jared and ivanka have recently purchased
a multi-million dollar
actually report is 30 million dollar
plot of land
somewhere in florida to build some kind
of estate so
i think that how this all shakes out is
not going to be known until
we see the full resolution of how donald
trump is ultimately going to sort of go
out is he going to eventually concede
and attend joe biden's uh
inauguration and act like an adult
is he going to go to mar-a-lago for
christmas and never come back
to the white house and not attend the
inauguration and then subsequently
how tied up will donald trump his family
and his businesses be on the basis of
investigations it's not just the
southern district of new york that is
reportedly
preparing a number of different
investigations into possible
wrongdoing by trump and his family there
are other
uh investigators and and state
prosecutors as well so i think we're
simply not going to know now the other
possibility that's been floated is
that the future of trump's children is
in media
as media hosts uh to be perfectly frank
i see that is very unlikely i think if
the future of the trump family is in
media
it would be this idea of trump starting
some kind of media outlet an alternative
to fox news
um more in the line of the
conspiratorial rantings of of outlets
like newsmax and oan
but it's really unclear whether trump
actually has the appetite for that
um and it's really not clear that trump
is going to have the appetite i mean
listen
when narcissists lose it is very
demoralizing and they
always come up with some excuse right
trump will rationalize his loss with
it was rigged and stolen plus i had the
pandemic which was just a timing thing
and if it weren't for the pandemic i
definitely would have won
he every narcissist with delusions of
grandeur will not
rationalize losing so that it's not
really losing
but it can often completely take the
wind out of their sails and listen
trump's 74
and it looks like he you know he moved
his legal residence from new york to
florida the
florida there's every indication that
he's going to be doing a lot of golfing
we may not see him do much and it's
possible his kids won't do that much
either
it's very tough to tell we will follow
it and we will we will know more before
before you know it uh hey david are
trumpists
really going to boycott the georgia
senate elections don't they realize
they'll just lose if they do it
yeah this is a great question earlier in
the week
we talked about how by insisting
that the georgia uh election was rigged
on november 3rd and that even though
donald trump really won this is the
claim from some on the right even though
trump really won
joe biden was given the election and the
electoral votes in georgia because of
some
theft or wrongdoing or subterfuge
we talked about how by saying that
you're at least
implying that the same would take place
on january 5th when we have these two
senate runoff elections which will
actually decide control of the senate
rafael warnock democratic challenger
against incumbent
kelly leffler uh john ossoff democratic
challenger to incumbent david perdue
when you insist it's rigged it's rigged
it's rigged
if people believe that they might say
why the hell am i going to vote if it's
rigged if my vote isn't going to count
if the democrats are going to steal it
anyway i'm going to stay home
and so over the last few days and at her
debate against
raphael warnock you saw kelly leffler
talking about this
they are now going to everybody must
vote
and it's sort of incoherent it's sort of
i guess the case they're making is
it's rigged but if we vote enough
we might be able to overwhelm the
rigging
the reality is that it's republicans in
georgia that have actually
rigged the elections if anybody has
through voter suppression tactics that
have been completely out in the open
voter purges removing people from voter
rolls
reducing early voting hours um so on and
so forth we've been covering it for a
very long time
do i think ultimately that many
republicans are going to stay
home because of the conspiracy theories
i don't think so i don't think so and
before
you know this has actually become a
little controversy within the show's
audience
on the monday show i said i have been
advocating for more participation and
more voting for a decade on this program
so i'm not going to suggest to
republicans that they not vote
because it goes against one of the
fundamental principles that i have
obviously i would rather republicans see
the light and vote for the right people
but i wouldn't be able to live with
myself if now i start saying stay home
republicans
but i did say i'm not going to go out of
my way
to change republican minds if they've
already been convinced not to
vote by claims that it's rigged and i
actually got a few emails from people
saying david why not tell republicans
not to vote
uh they're voting for absolutely
horrible people and again
it's the principle this is not a program
that activate
that advocates for not voting and i
understand if republicans stopped voting
then uh the left could easily win but
it's
if you know me you know that that's not
how i operate i know that many will say
why aren't you stooping to their level
they stoop to their level and they don't
care well i do care
i do care i i'm taking the high road on
that but
if republicans want to insist that they
shouldn't vote because it's rigged
by all means go ahead and do it and i
would gladly accept
republicans losing those two seats
because they believe
that their voting is actually rigged go
ahead but in the end
i think most republicans are going to
vote hey david
are democrats going to get destroyed in
2022
as most new parties in the white house
do
during their first midterm election so
we have a lot of different things
we there's a lot of sort of uh
milestones
that will be part of the 2022 midterm
elections
first of all these will be the first
midterms
after the removal of donald trump in
many ways
donald trump was sort of a crossing of
the rubicon
it was a before and after that we will
all remember in american politics
and so now that trump has been removed
is in the process of being removed
i believe that there is some uncertainty
as to what we would expect
in the first non-trump era midterms
number two
2022 will be the first election with the
newly drawn districts of the 2020 census
number three it is true that the party
uh
out of the white house tends to do well
in their first midterms
but i actually do think that the 2022
midterms could be midterms where
the democratic party does well even
though it wouldn't really line up with
the historical trend so there's a couple
different things
going on here first of all if joe biden
gets a second coronavirus stimulus
passed
and starts getting us out of the
pandemic which will of course be helped
dramatically by vaccines that are
soon to be approved and we see cases and
deaths declining
significantly in the second half of 2021
and into 2022 and we really he see
what feels like a return to normal by
standard
uh measures the economy does well
unemployment continues uh
decreasing significantly um gdp
recovers etc you could really see
democrats do very well in 2022
much like republicans did well uh in the
first midterms after 9 11 in 2002.
bush had post 9 11 and did well in those
midterms
biden could be the postcovid president
and democrats could actually do very
well in 2022.
the other signal and this is so early i
mean we're
we're getting to the end of the year
we're speculating here but it's so early
to really be thinking about this
if we continue seeing this slight shift
among suburban voters from the
republican party to the democratic party
that could be a big factor again
depending on what redistricting looks
like on the basis of this year's census
biden's 2022 suddenly doesn't look
nearly as bad or risky as many
first-term presidents
obama 2010 comes to mind obama 2010 was
a disaster you had the tea party
movement you had
yes some racism that was reflexively
coming out in 2010 you also have
in the senate democrats don't have as
many tough seats to defend in 2022
they will have to figure out the seat
held by mark kelly because that's up
again in 2022 i believe i hope i'm not
wrong about that
republicans will have to defend seats in
ohio wisconsin
florida those would be big fights and
then you are going to have some likely
incumbent republican retirements as well
could be pennsylvania could be north
carolina
chuck grassley in iowa could be a likely
retirement he's an old
significantly older guy it could be
close to 90
right by 2022. so the senate map
back in when was it hold on 27 2018
i guess after the 2018 midterms i've
been saying
i see 2020 senate as very tough for
democrats
i see 2022 senate as more of an
opportunity for democrats if they can
just roughly hold or gain a little bit
in 2020.
um we may indeed be heading in in that
direction so
i think that there's a real chance that
democrats actually
do really well in 2022 too early to tell
we'll be following it
and uh that will be let's get past the
inauguration let's start decreasing the
number of cases and deaths from the
virus let's really focus on that and
then
we will get to 2022 there will be time
we've got a great bonus show for you
today
get instant access by becoming a member
at joinpacman.com
coupon code available never mandatory
but available at your discretion
the coupon code fresh start all one word
all lower case
saves you gobs of money on a membership
we will see you then
thanks a lot for watching today's show i
just want to take a second to tell you
about today's sponsors nebia is a
revolutionary shower head that saves you
money by using
45 percent less water but with a stream
of water that's way more powerful
than what you get with other shower
heads to get 15 percent off
go to nebia.com pacman and use
the code pacman blinkist is the app that
helps you become a more well-rounded
person by letting you read or listen to
an entire nonfiction book in just 15
minutes
you can try it for free and get 25
percent off a subscription
by going to blinkist.com david pakman
if you're trying to quit smoking or
vaping check out lucy which is a
nicotine gum developed by caltech
scientists they'll ship it right to your
door and you can save 20 percent
when you go to lucy.co and use coupon
code pacman